Welcome to the lecture on database implementation.
So in the last lecture, we have looked at buffer management and how the database system organizes data and pages.
And these pages are buffered in memory.
And these are the low-level primitives basically of which we build everything else.
But for most high-level operation, pages are built too low-level.
So we rarely think in raw pages, I mean sometimes we do, but most of the time,
So we have data structures that are larger than a page, and we need a mechanism to handle
these.
The traditional way to organize data structures that cross multiple pages in the database
system are so-called segments.
Now, what do we need segments for?
It means the most obvious example are relations.
So if you want to store a relation in the database system, relations most likely larger
than a page if there's a lot of data in there.
Therefore, we need a mechanism to organize something into multiple pages.
But relations are not the only thing we store.
There are also many other things that we store in the database system,
for example, index structures, B3 or something.
It also consists of multiple pages and we need some mechanism to organize this.
Or internal data structures, for example, free space management.
So it tells us where there's free space available and so on.
And for management purposes, it's very convenient to treat this set of pages
as an entity.
Therefore, for example, if somebody does
drop table statement,
so if we send a secret statement that says
drop table foo, then of course,
this means we must now deallocate,
dealloc page number 11,
page number 17 and so on.
So this is, therefore we need a way to
talk about a set of pages, and we can manipulate them as entities. And so we do
this as a segment. Now what is a segment? In the first approximation a segment is
like a file in a file system. In a file system you create a new file and
then you can store data and you can read it back. This is more or less like we do
in a segment. Now I say more or less because there are some differences. For
For example, in a traditional file,
we expect that if, let's look at a file.
So if you have a file,
if you start here, then we'll start writing data.
So then you write here, of course.
So the file grows as needed.
So this is just as we also need to in a database system.
But we see that when we do write,
first we do write one, two, three, four, five.
So this is the order that we get in a file.
In the segment, we do not necessarily have this.
a file system, I took two things.
First is the amount of storage.
Second, there's an inherent order.
In a segment, there's not an inherent order.
And for good reasons, actually.
There are technical reasons why we don't want this.
Therefore, it's only a rough analogy.
So in a segment, it could be that we allocate
a number of pages, then we allocate another number
of pages, and then later, perhaps we allocate
something in the middle.
So this can happen.
So if allocation evolves,
and so this is a bit different from a file.
But we will come back to the difference in a moment
when we talk about different kinds of segments.
Just keep in mind, in the first approximation,
a segment is like a file-like structure.
So we allocate multiple pages
and we can grow the segment over time.
There are some differences,
linearity is usually not guaranteed.
Therefore, another way to think about a segment
instead of a file is perhaps to think of it
like virtual memory.
familiar with this from operating systems.
So when you look at what in an operating system,
we have an address space, a virtual address space
that we can address.
This is then mapped to physical data.
So this is also something similar to the segment.
So the segment allows me to talk about pages.
And the database system itself, the lower layers,
know how to map this conceptual page to a physical page.
So this is also the thing with the segment.
Now what is the interface that the segment offers to us?
So the most primitive interface of course is allocate and release.
So we can say I need a new page or you can say I forget this page, I don't need this page anymore.
So allocation happens all the time.
Of course if we grow it, it's more data than we allocate.
Now release is a bit more rare, but this can happen for example if you have a Btree and then
you delete something and then the Btree node is no longer needed.
then we can tell the database,
okay, here this page is free, I don't need this,
you can use it for something else.
So the basic imperative is allocate and release.
Then there are some other operations that we can do.
We can iterate over all pages,
so we can read from the beginning to the end.
This is very convenient if you want to do a table scan,
for example, so if you want to read everything
that is stored in a relation,
then we iterate over all the pages of the relation.
And so as the example I already gave,
whole segment if somebody does a drop table statement.
So says, please release all data.
And then this happens.
Now, this is something that I mentioned before here, we say
optionally offers a linear address space, or perhaps I should say, by default, we do
not get a linear address space.
Now, what does this mean?
So first let's make an example of this.
So this is my database system.
And then I have here relation one,
and this stores some data.
Then we store some single relation one.
Then afterwards, somebody else creates
some single relation data and some relation two.
Then again, some more data is inserted in relation one.
No problem.
So, as you mean, if we just grow over time,
you see that the segment here is not contiguous.
So we have here a number of pages in the first,
in the relation, and here is another number of pages that are not text each other, but
it doesn't matter.
It's okay.
So we can handle this.
Now what happens is, somebody does a SQL statement.
We say, drop table R2, and then suddenly we have a hole.
So now what the database system will do is, if you know R1 will allocate new pages, we
could grow at the end of course, but we don't do this, or at least potentially we don't
do this, because we might recognize there's a hole between these two parts that I can
close.
So if you could say instead of growing at the end, you grow here.
So then you make the hole smaller.
Even more fancy, if you look at this page here, we just say we can allocate and release new pages.
Usually what the systems do is something that is even more strange perhaps,
at least if you're only familiar with simple malloc free locations.
So you could, you can say the segment,
here segment.alloc.
So traditionally we say I need one page.
Now you could say for example,
or instead of saying one page,
I know so much data is coming.
You say, okay, I would like to have five pages,
because I see more pages.
Then what can happen here is,
and says, oh, you know,
here's a very convenient space available for you.
Then it says, okay, you get this page here
and you asked me for five pages, but I gave you eight.
So you get more pages than you asked for.
Now, and this is of course a bit surprising,
but so now everything is R1.
And this closing this hole is a very good idea
because then we, from an IO perspective,
then we have everything again next to each other.
So we can nicely sequentially scan this.
This is very good to reconstruct this.
So you get this answer here, you ask for five,
but you get, for example, seven.
So that's a whole is gone.
And so the interface here is even more complex.
So I said here, allocate five and reality,
for you can tell it, can give it two numbers.
For example, you could say, I need at least n pages.
So I could say, for example, one,
at least one page, but if you have more,
I think I can make use of five, for example.
And so this is basically the minimum,
and this here is a preferred size.
But nevertheless, the system can decide to give you even more,
because if it would just give you five,
then there's a small gap here remaining.
So if you would use five,
then you would have here two pages left.
And who can you give two pages?
So two pages is very little.
So we don't like to have small fragments of pages
sitting around.
Therefore we give you more than you asked for.
And now the database system, sorry,
the segment must make use of this.
But usually there's not a problem.
I mean, we will talk about free space management later,
but just saying, this is not a problem
because then the relation,
and we just have more space,
it's currently empty,
but when new tuppets are inserted in the future,
then the space will be filled.
So we can make use of the space,
at least in the long run.
Immediately, perhaps not,
but in the long run we can.
And therefore we take this,
and the great benefit of doing so
is that we greatly reduce the fragmentation problem.
So if you ever have implemented
a memory allocator yourself,
or if you look at how memory allocators work,
so often you have a problem that
patterns of allocation and release.
So you allocate something, then you allocate something else.
And then some more allocation, then you release something.
And then you do more allocation.
And then what often happens is you have here fragmentation,
which means you have small space left.
It's a small space here.
Nobody can make use of the space, because it's too small
to put anything useful.
And it just sits there between two blocks.
difficult to make use of this. And here in the segment world we avoid this
problem, namely if the moment that this plus guy would ask for the space you
would tell him, okay you wanted only so much but you get more, namely to fill this
gap completely, please make good use of this. So this is how the allocation in
the segment world works. Great for physical layout, so we greatly
reduces allocations so everything is good. Of course this has some perhaps surprising
consequences. Namely what happens is if you insert data in your database system,
yes you insert and you just write the first tuple, second tuple, third tuple,
fourth tuple and so on. And then at some point and you do select you most of the time will get
them back in the same order that you inserted. So you get them back one, two, three, four and so on.
But over time, because of this filling hold behavior, it could be that the tuple number 2000 and 2001 happened to be ordered between these two,
because there was a convenient free space available between them if you just fill them.
So it means that insertion order does not necessarily correspond to the result of a query.
First time you see this you might be surprised, but this is the technically reason for this.
But because, as I said, a segment is not really a file.
So a segment has no inherent order.
So we are allowed to insert data in the middle.
So basically, if this is my first data chunk, and this is my second data chunk, it's perfectly
fine to insert my third data chunk in the middle.
So we accept this.
So then we have a nonlinear order.
So the insert order does not correspond to result order.
And that we do this is a good idea, actually.
And this also matches the semantic of relations,
because if you think about this,
a relation has no inherent order.
So if you do a select star from relation,
so if you do this,
then you'll have no idea in which order
you will get the tuppets back.
It's not defined.
If you want an order,
then you have to do an order by.
If you don't do an order by,
then it's undefined what you get.
And therefore we are free to do exactly this.
Now there are a few cases, although I must say in the lecture I think we will not talk
about any of them, but there are a few data structures that want to have a so-called linear
address space.
So which means that a segment that absolutely wants that if the iteration order corresponds
to insertion order.
So that at once you insert the first block,
and then the second block,
that's the third block must come afterwards.
So there are basically two ways to guarantee this.
Either you really put the thread block
behind the last block,
but then you have potentially problems with holes,
or you do insert it in the middle,
but you remember what the original order was.
And then if somebody has iteration,
you first read one, and then two, and then three.
So if you have to guarantee linearity,
then this costs you something.
There's some overhead for providing this.
So this is basically like a file.
Now, so this is approximately like a file.
By default, we do not do this for good reasons.
If you have to provide this,
then this costs us something
because we must remember the order.
Okay, so, but in general,
segments are very convenient interface.
So this allows us to easily think about
sets of tuples, sorry, set of pages,
and to manipulate them quite conveniently.
So a segment is basically the logical collection of data
we have in our database system, in organizing pages.
Now, one question is,
how do we organize pages in segments?
Well, basically the same problem happens
if you want to decide how to organize blocks on disk to,
they say the same problems,
organize blocks on disk to your database system.
This is the same problem.
So how do we allocate physical storage units,
pages or blocks to a logical container?
And basically there are three kinds of approaches
that we want to look at.
The left and right are the most extreme.
The one in the middle is a middle ground, so a compromise between these two.
So the most extreme on the left, static file mapping.
This just says in the catalog, I remember that, for example, the segment starts on this
page, page 11, and then is so large.
Yeah, that's it.
Two numbers, first page, number of pages, very easy.
and it cost me very little, no space overhead,
or the performance is good.
But of course it's not very flexible,
because I can do this once and then that's it.
So it's called static file mapping.
So the other extreme is the one on the right hand side,
dynamic block mapping, where in the catalog
you have basically a list of all pages.
And then you say, okay, the first page is this one,
the second page is that one,
the third page is that one, and so on.
Or perhaps I shouldn't put the number differently.
So I say here, the number one, two, three are here,
and then this corresponds to physical page number 11, 15, 20,
or something like this.
So this is dynamic block mapping.
You have a dynamic list, and each points to a single page.
This, of course, gives you the maximum flexibility,
but it's also quite expensive.
And you see this box here itself,
this list can become quite large,
because for every page, you need an entry.
This is also problematic.
The middle ground between this here is the so called dynamic extent mapping, which says
we have a catalog, this contains a list.
But this list does not point to single pages, instead you point to extents, which means
to sequences of pages.
For example, here you could say page number 4711.
At this point here we have 20 pages.
So then we have one entry that points to a block.
another entry here points to another block. So this gives you flexibility in the dynamic block
mapping, but it's not as large as the dynamic block mapping. So we have a more compact representation
and so basically it's a mix between static file and dynamic block.
So the different pros and cons I think I've already said. Static file mapping is very simple
to implement, it's very low overhead, but resizing is difficult or impossible, depends on how you
but it's very problematic to resize.
First case, you might have to copy all the data,
which of course we don't want to do.
So this resizing is difficult.
Dynamic block mapping, this is the most flexible
because we can map each entry here to a block.
But problem is we have high administrative overhead,
we have additional interactions
also what we don't want to do.
So the dynamic extent mapping can grow,
but has less O-whites than the dynamic block mapping.
So in most cases, we will prefer the extent-based mapping.
So the dynamic is the middle one.
This is what we will prefer.
And I will see if we say a bit about implementation.
So the dynamic extent mapping grows by adding a new extent.
So basically, I have my mapping here at the beginning,
and then I need a little data, so I allocate a bit of space.
So then when my relation, for example, grows,
then just say, okay, here you have another segment,
and here you have another segment, and so on.
And the trick here is,
what you should do when you implement this,
you should grow this here exponentially,
which means that the second block
is a certain factor larger than the first block, and so on.
For example,
for example, factor 1.25,
Of course it's design choice which factor you use,
but there should be an exponential factor between them.
Now, why do you want to use an exponential factor
between extender and extender block sizes?
The great advantage of doing this
is that this bounds the number of extents.
I hope this is easy to see.
Now to illustrate this,
let's assume we will use not factor 1.25,
because there's a mass so difficult to do
without a calculator.
Let's assume we would use a factor of two,
that usually we do not do.
So two is a bit aggressive.
For example, if you have a factor of two,
then of course the first block here has a size,
let's say one, we will not start with one usually,
but I'm saying larger,
but let's assume the first one is one,
then of course we have two, then we have four, and so on.
So then after 10 steps, we have 1024.
And after 32 steps, we have something like 4 gigabytes, and so on.
We grow, and what we know is that the total number of extents that we have will be less
or equal to 64.
Why?
Because our address, we run out of address space after 64.
We cannot address them, at least on a 64-bit architecture, we cannot address them.
So we know that we will never have more than 64 extents.
And this is of course a very good thing, because this means that if you look back at this picture,
we can limit the size of this here one.
So this box, the size of this box has a limited size.
Which is a very good thing.
While in the dynamic block mapping, this here has unlimited size.
So if we implement exponential growth, then the dynamic extent mapping has a limited size.
And it depends on the factor we choose, we can bound it.
But usually this will be a few hundred at most.
So we have a few hundred entries.
and this makes our life much easier
because then we can store this interaction,
which we also have to store somewhere.
For example, we can guarantee
that this interaction always fits on a single page
just because it cannot grow beyond this.
Okay, therefore this point here
this greatly reduces complexity of implementation
and also improves I.O.
because when I have more and more consecutive pieces
of pages, this means I will do more and more
sequential I.O., this is a very good thing. Because sequential I.O. is faster than random I.O.,
therefore we greatly prefer that we have large sequential spans. And we get this here by using
this trick of exponentially growing each entry in my extent mapping. Now, I said in the beginning,
we have different kinds of segments, for example relations, indexes, and so on. We have many,
many different types of segments that we store.
And here we want to briefly classify them
using different dimensions.
So our first dimension here is
we have private versus public segments.
Now, what does this mean?
Private segment is something that is internal
to the data systems.
The user does not see this.
And usually shouldn't care.
Yeah, so this is some, for example,
we need some space to store which segments we have.
This is most likely a private segment.
So this is something that the user does not see.
While a public segment is an example, a relation.
The relation of course is something that the user sees
and we want to show it to user and say,
hey, this is so large.
And so if you ever use an administrative tool
and a database system, you might have seen this.
Like it tells you which kind of data occupies which space.
So therefore here we have public and private segments.
Now the second dimension here is permanent versus temporary.
The relation of course is permanent here because we don't want to lose our data.
So this is that we store forever as a permanent segment.
Now temporary segments we might have, for example, if we have a query that produces
intermediate results, so you perform a complex sort or group by, and this intermediate result
is so large that it does not fit in memory.
The database system must store it somewhere.
it can use a temporary segment.
So a piece of data,
this piece of data is allocated for the query,
but when the query is gone,
we can throw it away.
So we don't keep it,
we can only store it as long as my query is running.
And by the way,
for the system it's important to know
if the segment is permanent versus temporary.
Because for a temporary segment,
we don't really care so much.
If my system crashes,
then the temporary data is lost anyway,
so we don't care,
so we don't have to spend a lot of effort.
while the permanent segments of course we must keep alive,
therefore we must be more conservative in what we do with our data.
Okay, a third dimension is largely historically if you ask me,
because they exist in commercial data systems,
but few people ever see them.
So we have automatic versus manual segments,
most of the segments nowadays are automatic.
Now what is the difference here, the question is,
can you automatically access the data or do you have to do anything?
makes sense if, for example, your data is stored
on near-line storage.
So it's not online, but the user has to do something.
For example, install an external disk.
Usually we don't want to do this,
but you have to install some physical medium
until you access the data.
So this is an example of manual segments
where users to access this.
I think this is meant largely out of fashion.
Most segments nowadays are automatic.
And so we don't want to manually do something.
But of course, this system do support this.
segments that are not always available.
And the last dimension here is with recovery or without recovery,
so this is related to what I said before.
So an example of intermediate results.
In my relations with my real data, of course, I need recovery,
which means if I crash, I must reconstruct all the data so that nothing is lost.
But if I have just intermediate results, then I don't need recovery.
I can just throw them away.
Another example of something where you might not need a recovery,
but he's potentially not, is,
or as I said, might not.
Might not in the sense that mostly people recover
this regardless, but I know a few people who don't.
So the example I say now is an exception, if you wish.
Mostly the system will recover this.
But there are some people who do not recover
as the index structures, like B-trees.
Now, why don't they recover the index structures?
The argument is, first, crashes are rare.
So most of the time, the system doesn't crash.
So the system works all the time, and then if you shut it down, then we shut it down
in a clean fashion, so nothing bad happens.
A real crash, like a power failure or so, a real hard crash is rare.
And in the example with index structures, you could say, in the unlikely event that
my system goes down in a hard crash, then of course my index structure on disk might
be corrupted.
consistent state, but I can always throw away my index structure and rebuild it.
Because the index points to the original data, therefore I can forget all my index structures
and I can just rebuild them if needed.
Now is it worthwhile to do this?
It depends on how likely it is that you crash and how fast your index reconstruction is.
But let's say I know a few people who have implemented this, who say I don't recover
my index.
advantage of course is that index is faster
so you pay less overhead
for updating your index
so you speed up your index
you willingly
accept that your index might be corrupted
but if this
is really rare then you say okay
we accept this and if this happens
then just throw it away and rebuild my index
yeah
so this is the four main
dimensions with which we can differentiate
different types of segments
combination you choose, this differs in how complicated this segment is and how
much effort or how much cost this segment causes when you for example update.
Recovery for example costs you something or permanent solute of course
positives cost you something. Actually this may be talk of course we come to
this when we talk about recovery in the lecture but I'm just saying writing
something permanent to disk is surprisingly difficult. So it's much more
difficult than you might think perhaps at first glance. Now why is it difficult?
Just as a teaser to what we will look at later. I said a page is for example
16 kilobyte in size. Now you say I changed something in my page so I want to
write it to disk. So how do you do this? How do you write the 16 kilobyte of data to disk?
Now there are different interfaces which you could use. For example, the most primitive one
perhaps is a P-Write. So this is the most simple interface. We just say give it here, give it a
file handle and then you give it a pointer here to the buffer pointer and you give it a size for
in this case 16 kilobyte and then the operating system will do the write for you. Okay this is
most simple way to write. Now what is bad about this interface is you don't know what operating
system will do. In particular, it could be that during this period, if you are really
unlucky, you get a power failure. Now, what part of the 16 kilobytes has been written
to disk? Everything? Nothing? Only the first half? You have no idea. This also depends
on the hardware. For example, there are some battery buffer disk graphs, which by the way
great idea. A battery buffer disk drives where you can put your write in a buffer and then the
drive guarantees you that it will write out everything because if a power failure happens
it will use a battery and then to write out whatever is in the buffer. So this greatly
simplifies your life. But if you don't have a battery buffer disk drive then you might get a
partial write which means for example that everything up until here has been written
and the rest has not. This is an absolutely nightmare. It's very difficult to prevent,
These are things that you have to care about when you want to have permanent storage.
If you have temporary storage, then you say, who cares?
If I have a partial write, and only the first half of my page is written, then I crash,
I don't care at all, because the moment I come back, I will throw away the temporary data anyway.
So you can choose a cheaper write mechanism,
if you want to do this permanently, usually you will write twice.
This is a standard technique to guarantee persistency here.
And if you don't want to do this, and you know the data is temporary, then you say,
okay, I don't care, I just write this and this.
So this just shows you that the knowledge about the segment has quite some effect on
how you can operate with your hardware and with your operating system.
Okay, oops, sorry.
Now, which kind of segments do we have in our system?
Usually, a database system will have at least two low-level segments.
sense that you don't see them. I mean of course in the lecture we talk about them, but as a user you
have no idea what these are. So the first segment that you will have is
so-called segment inventory which basically keeps track of all pages that
are allocated to segments. This is perhaps to come back to the file system
analogy, this is like a directory of segments on top of your files.
So we need a way to remember which, so if you have a segment number one, two, three,
consists of, no, whatever, for example page number 11, 10 pages and so on.
So this kind of information must be stored somewhere and this somewhere is
so-called segment inventory. So this must organize educating pages to segments.
okay and for this we can implement this as extend list or page table or
different many different ways we can implement this. So this is the most low
level primitive basic that we need and the second low level segment that we usually
will have is the so-called free space inventory so this keeps track of free
pages so we must know which pages are free. So first of course we have
There are actually two kinds of free space inventory.
One is that it really knows which page is unused.
So this allows me to grow a segment so that if I need pages for a segment, I must be able
to find this.
For this we need free space inventory.
And we also need a second mechanism that depends on how you implement this.
Might be inside actually the first one or might be a separate data structure.
There are different ways to build this.
We need a second mechanism that says, okay, I want to insert a tuple of size 200 bytes.
for this tupper. This is also what we call a free space inventory. Now these two aspects,
free page versus free space on a page might be the same data structure or might not. It depends on
your implementation. And we can implement this also differently. For example, we can use a simple
bitmap. If you just want to figure out which page is completely free, we use one bit per page
and this tells me that okay this page is free, you can put a segment on this or this page is
occupied and then we might then for example remember how much is occupied or
just say it's occupied yes or no. But this is not the only way to implement this.
We can also use free extents with basically a list of free pages. So this is just like
basically you can for example implement this by saying all free pages are
allocated to certain special segments that owns all the free space.
There is also one way to implement this.
So these are the internal segments that are not user facing.
There are of course also user facing segments that people really care about.
For example the schema.
So the database schema must be stored somewhere so that we know which relations exist and
all this kind of stuff.
So the database schema must exist somewhere.
Then we need segments for relations.
Each relation is most likely a segment so that we can store all the tuples in a relation
You might have temp segments, like if we need intermediate results for queries, so if you want to store this somewhere, then this is stored in the temp segment.
We might also have, for example, index structures and so on. Index structures and many other things.
So these are the classical things that we store in database systems.
For each of them we will most likely have a different segment type even.
Okay, now when we talk about how database system works internally, so in particular concerning storage,
there are two dimensions that we are particularly interested in.
namely how do you first how do you perform page replacement concerning
updates and most of both the images effect updates as the first how you
perform page replacement and second how do you cope with write out when you're
done with the transactions these two dimensions here are called force and
steel okay now what does this mean so if he if he are my system runs a steel
This means I can take away a page even though the page contains an uncommitted change.
So let's say this is a page.
So let's say if this is page number 11.
So as long as this page is unmodified I can clearly throw it away all the time.
Because if I run out of memory I just throw away the page no problem because I can just read it back from disk.
Okay this is the easy case.
So now the not so easy case is somebody here has performed an update.
Now the data is modified. So page is dirty. Again I run out of memory. Now what
do I do? Am I allowed to remove page 11 from memory? So can I steal page
number 11? And clearly if I can do this then I have more flexibility because I
can reuse memory as I need, it doesn't matter if it's modified or not. The downside is if I do this
then suddenly I must remember that my page 11 contains dirty data because this update here
was not committed yet. So nobody else must see this. Also if for example I crash, I assume I steal
the page, I write it to disk, then I crash, then I come back up again, then this update here must be
gone and because it was not committed therefore this update here must be removed from the page
so still gives me flexibility but also cost me something second dimension is force now the
question of forces again i have a page with a change here yeah page number 17 contains also
some kind of update now the transactions that performs this update commits yeah and
And now what do we do about this?
So what do we do about this page here?
Do we write this to disk in the moment that the commit comes?
So this is called a force strategy.
So force means if the commit comes, I write all pages that are affected by this transaction
to disk.
Of course, the advantage is if I crash afterwards, everything is on disk.
on disk. Disadvantages are I write to disk more often than I have to.
Because every time somebody commits I write it to disk. If I write a no-for
strategy then I can keep it in memory. Of course this means now that
potentially a page is never written to disk. If a page is updated
all the time, so a frequent update to this page, then this page will always be
hot and always be modified and potentially nobody writes it to disk.
It could be that you have days or months of a dirty page that is not going to disk if
you are really unlucky.
So this is also not so good, so you don't like this.
If you want to avoid this, then of course we also must build some complicated mechanism.
So now which quadrant do we want to leave?
So the easiest box of course is this one.
So this is the easy box, but unfortunately we want to be the opposite.
usually this one here. And I said we want to be steal no force which means we can evict a page
from memory even though it's dirty and we don't write it to the disk even though the transaction
is committed. So this is what we want to do we want to be steal no force but this is the most
complicated one. Okay and we will come in later the lecture come to a recovery and we will look
exactly these problems again. Now one problem with dirty changes is we are
not the only one who uses the database system. There is one transaction that uses the database system.
This can of course modify all the changes that it wants until the commit comes.
But what about the other users? The other users are not allowed to see my
changes until I did a commit. How do we ensure this? Of course one
So if this is my page, so this is page 11, then I have modified something here.
I could just say, as long as this here is not committed, nobody else is allowed to read this page.
Easy or relatively easy to implement, so we just lock the page, say nobody else can read it.
But it's undesirable to do this, because you get poor concurrency from this.
because nobody else can read the page, everybody blocks on this.
Also we have this recovery problem. Remember when
we said here on this slide, when we run a steel strategy
it could be that the modified data goes to disk.
If we crash, we must somehow get back to the original data. How do we do this?
Also not so easy.
Now one particular elegant or nice way to cope with this problem is the so-called shadow
paging.
Now what is the idea of shadow paging?
The idea is that you have your...
So let's say I start with my database system and just fill seven pages.
So this is...
Oh sorry, six pages.
This is my original dataset, this one.
Here's six pages.
the first six pages. Now if somebody modifies page six, if you take this page here and modify
this, what we do is we create a copy of six. Now let's call this seven. So we have a copy
of six. This is page seven. And then we have a page table that says which page is current.
As here we say page 7 is the current page.
Now if the transaction who brought, who multiplied page 6 to 7 crashes, then we can just undo
this update in this directory here because we still have the page 6.
So we can just undo this change here and then we are back to where we come from.
Also, if a concord transaction comes, then it can just read the page 6 and not the page 7 and it still gets a correct version.
The same here later, we updated page number 3, then we end up to this page number 8 and we modify page number 8 and everybody else can still read the page 3.
Now if the transaction that modifies 5, 6 and 8 did commit, then this becomes the official page.
And then now of course internally pages, original pages were 6 and 3.
These become free, so then we can reuse them and put other data on this.
This is so called shadow paging.
Basically we have logical pages.
So here you see in this example here we have six logical pages.
This is 6 of course, not a 4.
6 logical pages.
These are somehow mapped to physical pages.
We use the page table.
The dirty page, a page that is not committed yet,
is stored in a shadow copy.
We have both copies available, both the original ones at the shadow.
Then at some point, of course, we make it official again.
So we copy here the 6 to 6.
6827 and then its official page and then that's it.
So it's a relatively simple mechanism to implement and provides both recovery and transaction isolation.
Great. So the advantages of shadow paging are that the clean data is always available on disk,
easy to recover and we can use the transaction isolation.
Now the downside is, two downsides. First, my page access logic is more complicated
because I must always look into this page table interaction here to check which page should I read
and what is the current version of the data that you look at. This is also already not so nice,
but this is not what really stopped people from doing this. The more unpleasant part is this one
here. Distraced data locality. This is really really an unpleasant behavior because if you
think about this, in the original data here, all pages were next to each other. Here, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
So, if I want to read them, I just start with one, then sequentially read them from disk. This is, of course, as fast as I can be.
Now, if I have a shadow page table like this, then I have no longer a
sequential run. I have here a sequential run, then here a sequential run, then here a sequential run,
and here a sequential run. Basically, I have four runs instead of one. So, in worst case, I do three
seeks. Now if you include the first things and even four. So here we have a seek, here we have a seek, here we have a seek, here we have a seek.
So we no longer have nice sequential access patterns. So I have random I.O.
And remember random I.O. is slow, therefore people don't like this.
Nowadays very few people use this on disk based systems. Because on a disk based
system it's so terrible to do a seek. So extremely expensive. And therefore you
On the other hand, as I mentioned last time, hardware is changing too and on an SSD for
example it might be less disastrous than on a rotating disk.
Even on SSDs there are problems with this but let's say it's not as bad.
Or even more extreme example, in main memory you can do this.
Because main memory has little effects with random O, I mean it is not true.
There are also some random effects, but this only occurs within a page.
If you jump from one page to another, it doesn't matter, because it's the same if it's physically
next to you or not.
So within memory, you can implement something like shadow paging to isolate transactions.
And there it's actually affordable to do this.
So shadow paging is still interesting to use, but not on a disk-based system, only for other
applications.
Now, instead of shadow paging, you can also implement a different strategy.
It looks a bit different, but it's conceptually quite similar.
So it has a similar idea, namely, we also have original data and we have a copy, but this
here is now called a delta file.
So how does this work?
So this is my original data. So let's say I have here again six pages.
Oops, sorry. One, two, three, four, five, six. Now I assume I want to update page number six.
Then what I do is I copy six to my delta. So this is my delta here. I copy six to my delta,
then I have it here and I change it here to 6 prime. Okay, so after I make my copy I can change
it in place. Now when I commit, so if somebody, if my transactions that manipulate C to C prime
just commit, then I just throw away 6 because I no longer need it, it has been committed. If my
transaction aborts, then I still have the 6, then I forget the content of 6' and
instead I copy my 6 back into the abort. I copy my 6 into 6'.
So I use the delta for recovery. Of course I can also use it for
transaction isolation because I still have the copy available. But the thing is
the copies vanish over time. So if a transaction ends either with a commit or a board, afterwards
the copy is gone. So conceptually I update in place, I just delay the in place update. Or let's
say I have the original data still in the delta file. Now of course we can implement a delta file
in two flavors. Namely the question is where do you put the original data and where do you put
the data, dirty data. So what I draw first was I had the original data, the unmodified
data in the delta and then the modified data in the main file. Both have pros and cons.
If you do this then of course a commit is cheap because on the commit I just throw away the data.
But an abort is expensive because I must copy back the page. If I do the other way around,
If you store the dirty data in the delta and the clean data in the original file, then
the commit is expensive and the abort is cheap.
Because an abort doesn't do anything.
And now, which of the ones should we prefer?
Depends on what you optimize for a commit or abort.
I would say usually you optimize for a commit.
Because you assume that most of your transactions will commit, so abort should be the exception
and therefore let's make the commit cheap.
So we put the original data in the delta
and the modified data in the main file.
And then the commit is cheap and the rollback is expensive.
This is usually what we want to prefer.
But you could implement, of course, both.
Now, delta files have some advantages of shadow paging.
First of all, the best advantage, if you ask me,
is we preserve data locality.
So afterwards, after everything is committed,
where data is again nicely consecutive on disk,
so we get a nice read performance.
This is what we want.
So we don't mess up locality.
Also, we don't mix up clean and dirty pages
and different files.
This also makes your recovery easier.
It's easier to recover from this,
but for me, locality is the most advantageous thing.
Now, of course, there are some disadvantages.
First, we do more I.O.
And because in the moment, I do a copy here,
I originally had one page.
Before I modify, let's say this is page 6,
before I modify page 6 I must make a copy and write it to disk.
That's why I have a copy on disk.
So this of course cost me all.
Now the second write is free.
If I do 6' or 6' doesn't matter because I still have my original 6
as long as nobody commits.
Now if I commit, of course I copy it back.
Then I write again.
but I must do for every update I must do one additional write. So this is a disadvantage.
I do more I.O. and second disadvantage of course is that either the commit or the abort becomes more expensive.
It depends on how you implement it. So the way I said we store the original data in an extra file,
since abort becomes more expensive, the commit is cheap. You can choose which one you want to make cheap.
And of course you also have to keep track on the data pages, which is also not so super trivial.
Remember we have multiple threads, we have concurrently updated this, but we can definitely implement this.
Regardless of the disadvantages, the delta files are usually preferable over shadow paging.
So if I would implement a system, I would rather prefer delta files than shadow paging because of this problem here.
Preserve data locality.
This is a really great property because in the long run we get better performance when
if my data is nicely consecutive.
So the delta file is actually quite a good idea.
Okay, so this brings me to the end of the storage part.
Now next we want to at least start a bit with looking at the access path.
I said access path, this is kind of a generalization of index structures and relations.
the data that you store in your database system.
And so we, to orchestrate the access to the data,
we need some different data structures
and that we will look at, of course,
in this order that we write here.
So first we need some kind of free space management.
So as I mentioned this before,
so we need some mechanism to figure out
where is free space where they can put more data.
And this has to happen reasonably fast.
Then we need data structures for the data itself.
So, first of all, this is internal if you wish.
This is here.
To know where to put data, this is, let's say it's relations for example.
Then we need some data structures for unusually large data.
For example, extreme example of course, a blobs, binary large objects, or even more harmless,
large strings.
So if the user stores gives me a large string, I might have to do something.
Large strings, we need that for this.
And finally of course we need index structures to speed up access.
Because if I have many million tuples in my database, I usually don't want to look at
all of them.
just if a search was a specific one and need some way to speed up the search.
Okay, so these are the four parts and we now want to look at them in sequence.
Today I will not be able to look at all of them, but at least I will start looking at
the first two points.
So free space inventory.
So the first question is, a user doesn't insert and gives me a tupper and might know for example
My tuple has a size of, I don't know, let's say tuple.
My tuple might have a size of, for example, 200 bytes.
Where do I put it?
And particularly if you see not all tuples are the same size.
Could be there's the next tuple or the previous tuple is a tuple of a short string.
Therefore, the previous tuple might just have, for example, 50 bytes.
And I might have to put them in different places because I organize my data in pages.
So my pages have a certain field degree.
So this is page, page one.
And this is page two.
And then this here might be full up to here.
And this here might be full up to here.
And then clearly a small tuple I can squeeze in here.
but a larger tuple might only fit in here.
And this, by the way, if I do this in different order,
so if I do the second tuple after this,
let's call this tuple 2 and tuple 1,
could be that tuple 1 ends up here because there's enough space,
tuple 1, while tuple 2 has to go here,
or can go here, tuple 1 cannot go here.
Tuple 2 can go here because there's enough free space.
And this is also cause for when a selection order, so the results order when you select
does not correspond to insert order.
Just because of the free space at the end of a page, could be that something small does
still fit and something large doesn't.
Okay, now we need a way to figure out where should we put this.
And yeah, so we need to quickly find out what is a page that can still hold 200 bytes or some other amount of space.
Now the traditional way to do this is to use a so-called free space bitmap,
which basically means that for each page in your segment, you have a large array.
No, sorry.
You have a large array that for each page in your segment contains an entry.
Usually not even one byte, just half a byte per page.
Of course you can be more generous and give it one byte per page, and you can be more accurate.
But a traditional implementation looks something like this.
You just give four bits, which means half a byte, so one nibble, half a byte, half a byte per page.
So four bits describes the first page, the next four bits describes the second page, and so on.
So here we describe the field degree for each page.
and we maintain this for each page and now if an insert comes and wants to insert new data
then we look at this array and then we figure out okay what is a page that contains enough free space
for my tupple and the first page that doesn't contain enough free space I insert two and then
of course I update this field degree if it has changed. Okay so this is a high level here we have
bitmap and for every page we reserve for example 4 bit then we store the field degree.
Now one question of course is do you store how much data do you store or do you store
how much free space do you have? It doesn't really matter yes because if one is just so
So we know that free is equal to page size minus used.
So it does not really matter if you store used or free.
Both is basically the same.
You can compute one from the other.
Usually I would say you will store used, so how much you have used, just because then
we have conveniently can interpret all zeros here as pages empty. But this is really up to you,
so this doesn't really matter. Both is fine. Just one of the two you will use. Okay, so now we must
encodes the fill degree of a page in four bits. And of course, four bits is not a lot.
Some systems are even more crazy and use only two bits or even one bit per page.
I think this is not good. One bit is really too little.
Two bits is a bit better, but also not very accurate. With four bits, we can already write a bit more accurate information.
At least we have 16 different states that we can have.
Of course, the more bits you have, the more accurate you are.
So more bits you use, the larger your free space inventory becomes.
And now you could say, hey, disks are free or disks are cheap, I don't care about space
utilization, let's use 8-bit.
But the problem is also if you make it larger, scanning it becomes slower.
So you have a certain incentive of making it small.
But nevertheless, I think 4-bit is the minimum that you want to use.
Okay, so let's assume we use 4 bits.
So now how can we encode my use, my space utilization with just 4 bits?
One way to do this is to say I just do linear interpolation.
Yes, basically I encode there in these 4 bits size of my data divided by page size divided by 2 to the power of number of bits.
For example, if I use 4 bits and by 16, so I say here, data size divided by 1 16th of the page size and then round it up.
If I round this up, it uses as field degree, then I can, from the 4 bits, decide do I have enough space for my incoming tuple.
Of course, there is some inaccuracy because I always round up, which means that my accuracy is only page size divided by 16.
if you have a 16 kilobyte page and then I have 16 states then my my my blocking
factor here is one kilobyte so I basically the last kilobyte I cannot
fill easily and because the moment that I cross into the last kilobyte by page
looks full yeah my my field degree will be maximum it's a moment that I come
in this is last one kilobyte of the page so that means it's a bit difficult to
makes a page completely full. So this is a bit of a problem so I might have a problem of loss of accuracy.
Therefore I can say instead of having a linear scale I prefer a logarithmic scale.
So instead of doing linear correlation I say I store the logarithms and then I can describe the extremes very well.
here now we use logarithms of text size. So this here means 1, 2, 4, 3 is 4, 8, 16 and so on.
So the exponential growth and this of course allows me to describe the small values very precisely.
While in linear interpolation it loses accuracy.
see. Or you, if you do this by the way, you probably don't want to do this with text size,
you want to do this with free size. Because we prefer the case when we nearly run out of space,
we want to know this, then we want to make it completely full. Or of course you could do even
a combination of two, for example, you could say I am linear, so I have 16 possible values.
Let's say I use eight of the values with a linear scale and then, oh sorry, here's a linear one,
eight for the linear and then eight for logarithmic scale. This is probably even better because with
the logarithm, there's a problem that at some point the values become too large and we don't
care about them anymore. So you might use a combination of these. Also, you mean, my example
smallest value is one, then we have,
so we have one, two, four, eight, and so on.
This is, we probably do not care about one and two,
because no tupper will have only one byte or two bytes.
So we might have alignment, and so on.
So we might, might be that our tuppers
are multiple of four, for example, anyway.
So therefore I know my smallest possible value is four,
and then I go only exponential afterwards.
carefully hand constructed tables that says for example,
value 15 means full, value 14 means four byte left,
or we didn't four bytes, but perhaps two is more,
and let's say eight byte left,
then 15 means 16 left, 60, sorry,
go the wrong direction.
13 of course. 13 means 16 left, 12 means 32 left, 11 means 64, 10 means 128 and
Then, afterwards we go to linear.
Then we, I was going the wrong direction, the numbers here.
9, 8, and afterwards we do linear scale, for example.
This is linear scale.
This allows me to make my pages fairly full and I still can describe the rest of the pages
using a nice linear scale.
So this is some kind of encoding you will choose.
Then these four bits are actually sufficient to describe your fill degree of your page quite accurately.
So we can find for every table an appropriate place where we can insert this.
We use this to encode the free space.
I already said it doesn't really matter if you encode the free space or the used space.
because one is just page-minus-the-assass,
so it doesn't matter what you use,
but with a few bits we describe which state we are,
then we choose whatever we need for our insert
to find an appropriate page.
Okay, so how do we use this?
So when we insert data, we compute the required free-stress inventory entry.
For example, I might require that, if I now describe used instead of free,
I might require that my page has an entry of at most seven because I know that if it is seven or less my data fits
So then I scan the free space inventory for a matching entry and then I insert the data on this page and of course I
Update the entry if I go to a next if my search
Was large enough to cross into the next free space inventory category then of course we update the entry.
So this is the idea. We scan insert.
Now, so this is pretty simple to implement.
Only problem is, this can be surprisingly expensive.
The problem is, if I scan this inventory,
then I have a linear effort.
Yes, I start with the first page and then I check.
Of course, I have a linear effort.
Now, the free space inventory,
it's safe is not so super large.
Yes, it's pretty small.
If you have 16 kilobabit pages,
then one page of free space inventory is enough
to cover half of a gigabyte of data.
So you don't have a lot of pages,
but nevertheless it costs you something.
And I can tell you from personal experience,
the first time I implemented this,
I implemented this naively, so I was about the book,
and I then read some experiments and everything worked great.
And then I started inserting 10 gigabytes of data,
and suddenly the system became slower and slower.
And now why does this happen?
Of course, if you have 10 gigabytes of data, we have 20 pages with free specimen, each
of them contains a few thousand entries.
As we are checking thousands and thousands of entries, and this costs something.
So suddenly my performance was dominated by scanning the free specimen.
So this was costing performance.
Of course, it's a bad idea.
So now how can we make this scan cheaper?
Pretty easily actually, because we know that there are only 16 free space inventory values
anyway.
We know this.
And therefore we can cache the next matching page or perhaps the next set of pages, a range
of pages.
And so we just remember what is the next page that has this entry.
And this cache works very well because most pages are static.
them to the database and then most of the time you don't do anything with them.
They just sit there and you read them perhaps later but you don't modify it
most of the time. Of course it could be that you do a bulk operation that you
delete all entries or so that's okay that from time to time it
the cache has to be invalidated but most of the time the cache will be
correct. So if you just remember the last the first if you just remember the
first page with the first with a certain fsi value
then this then I never have to check before
I just check after. So this is my inventory and I might remember for example the first page with an entry of seven is here
So if somebody asked me for seven I go here and I start checking
Now this should be the correct page. If not, if it's not the correct page
Continue to the right until I find the first
Correct matching page and then of course I update my cache. So I never again
search for the page with the value of seven
than this cache value here.
So this is my cache.
And so I only scan the end of my
three space inventory and never check before.
And now it could be, as I said,
that somebody deletes something in the middle here.
Then of course I have to perform the delete.
Then of course I must update my cache,
but this happens rarely.
Most of the time we don't do this.
Then I read the rest again,
but then after the first scan
again I catch this and I will never look at this again okay and this works quite
well because segments tend to grow at the end so that we are most of the time
we only event at the end then we don't have this expensive checking here okay
so and then we then we perform allocations then we benefit from the
knowledge of the application knowledge that we have yes of this by the way true
Pages we have made, the example previously when we talked about segments, and also about tuples.
Like for example, you could say, hey, I, so either you allocate a phase of data or you
insert, for example, a number of tuples.
If somebody has an insert statement, yeah, so here you have an, for example, if a statement
looks like this, insert into R, then here we do a select.
So then of course we have a single tuple that is currently coming and we need a space for
the single tuple.
Yeah, but we already know, or we could know, that there will be more tuples coming.
So we know because the select produces a number of tuples, we might know this and we can make
use of this knowledge.
Another example here is that we might, where we need allocations, very large data items,
we talk about them, not today but in the next section, but it's also something where we
And so what we want of course is that allocations are close to each other and what we can do
when allocating is we can give the system hints. Basically we say
it's a single tuple, therefore say allocate and need for example 200 bytes.
Yeah, the same minimum is 200 because I must put the next tuple in there.
200 bytes.
But I could know already that there are more tuples coming.
minimum but if you have for example space for I don't know it's 20 kilobytes this is good
I'm sorry kilobytes yeah so therefore the system can make use of this information say okay 20 or
200 is a minimum but if I have a better spot to fit the 20 I will do this and I will give the
caller 20 kilobytes until of course that you have 20 kilobytes and then you can place the next
also next to the first one.
So this way we reduce fragmentation.
So we tend to, we prefer to put data next to each other.
And we might be even more crazy for templates,
we will not do this because we have nothing we can put there.
But for segments, I made the example already,
where we might do over allocation.
So where the segment, the user of the segment says,
I need five pages.
I said I prefer two pages,
but I know how to make use of five pages.
And the system regardless says, you asked me for at most five, but you know, I had seven.
Please take the seven because it fits better in my allocation and my memory layout if you take seven.
And therefore, it gives you more than you asked for.
So it's called over-allocation.
And by doing so, we reduce fragmentation.
And this is a really nice thing.
And I would say perhaps a bit unfortunately, regular programming languages do not support this.
even though I think more people could benefit from this.
So this is actually a very good interface.
In an example where this makes sense, even though leaving the world of database systems,
if you think about something like a vector, in a programming language,
so let's say you need memory for, for example, vector int, and then here we have a .
So then we insert here, we do, we push back, so we grow.
Yeah, so we grow over time.
And of course at some point
the physical memory must be increased.
So first it's small, then as we grow,
we make it larger and larger.
Yeah, and the funny thing is,
so for example the vector itself might say,
okay now I please I need space for 20 entries. Now internally this memory is
allocated either from the C library or from the operating system and this
underlying layer will have a kind of blocking factor too. This is just
something that is invisible to you. So basically what you ask for
amount of memory for example now so this year if it's C++ it will perform a call
example and this call of you might internally for example call malloc so
this is a low-level allocation primitive from C we could say for example malloc
don't know I need for 20 entries I need good overhead let's say I need 88 bytes
for example yeah and of course you can get back a pointer here and you know for
sure that this pointer here has enough space for 88 bytes.
But it could be, so you asked for 88,
but it could be that in reality this has enough space
for, for example, 96.
Because of how the allocation internally works,
the malloc cannot give you arbitrarily
small pieces of data.
It depends on implementation.
But most malloc implementations cannot give you
arbitrarily small pieces of implementation.
you asked 288 but you got 96 but you don't know this.
So you got more than you asked for,
but you have no way to know this.
Now if you could know that you got more,
then the vector could be smarter and could realize,
oh, I wanted to grow to 20,
but in reality I grew to have enough space now
for example, 20, what did I say, 21 at least.
So you can make use of this extra space.
Would be great, unfortunately there's no portable way
In fact, there is a way to do this.
I don't remember the name, but I have to look it up in a moment.
So there's a function here that is called malloc usableSize.
This is not, unfortunately, not super portable. In Linux you can do this.
I was saying it's not a POSIX function even.
Let me briefly check.
No, it's not a POSIX function.
So this is a GNU extension here.
It's not standardized.
Unfortunately, there's no standard way
to do this GNU extension.
So then you can ask the melancholytect is this.
So how much space do I have?
So you could exactly do this trick.
Use the extra space that you got.
And it would be a good idea to do this.
Only problem is we make other tools
So we'd be unhappy if you do this.
Or actually in this case address center
will just tell you exactly how much you allocated.
So it will not give you useful answer back.
So malloc usable size is a bit fishy.
But in principle this idea of using over-allocation
is a very good idea.
Database systems do this routinely.
Programming languages do not.
But perhaps they should.
Because if you do over-allocation
it helps you to fight fragmentation.
Okay, now so much for the allocation.
So up to now we talked about figuring out where do we find enough space to store my data.
Now we have to think about what do I really put in my, so how do I put my records in a
page.
I realized this page should have enough space and I must somehow physically do this.
And the traditional way to do this is to use a so-called slotted page.
I just checked my time. So I have only quarter an hour left. I think I will stop here. I will not do slot bases.
Perhaps you remember slotted pages from the introduction to databases. Then great. Please look at this again.
Because this is what databases really internally use. But I will need more than 15 minutes to talk about slotted pages.
and I don't want to cut the explanation in the middle, therefore I stop here.
So I'm just saying tuples are internally stored in pages, stored in pages that we will look
at in the next lecture, and we use the free space inventory to figure out which page has
enough free space to fit a tuple.
Okay, then on top of this, in the next lecture we will build pages with tuples, which can
be used to handle extents.
If we look at the record layout, how does that mean?
Here we just draw a box, what is stored inside this box.
So this is where we look at the next lecture.
And then what we do if my record is too large for pages,
this is also what we cover next.
Okay, so I will stop here today, and then I hope you also,
I don't, unfortunately cannot attend,
but at least listen to my lecture next week.
Okay.